[Applaudissements]
erika moulet sachez que erika moulet en
fait je vais prononcer un mot dans un
instant et aux mots clés erika moulet
sera persuadé qu'il y aura un film porno
derrière la voilà au cabba est un peu
gêné d'accord vous voulez que je fasse
cela reste tout de suite voulez qu'on
fasse tout de suite vous allez voir à
chaque fois que je dirais le mot tient
trois cochons lavacant mort et erika ça
va et vous cyrine très bien vous ne
trouvez pas un petit peu coquin
aujourd'hui car tu vous qu'il ya
derrière
je découpe à cyril un oui un problème de
ce qui se passe il faut que vous veniez
ici parce que là il ya quelque chose qui
se passe que les gens ne doivent pas
voir
excusez moi mesdames et messieurs il ya
un problème je vais reprendre l'antenne
pendant quelques instants
[Rires]
parce qu'une khelil et régna cette heure
c'est zéro
qu'est-ce qu'il ya jérôme jérôme revon
il ne faut pas mettre la caméra sur
cyril 1
sur cyril il y as derrière vous cyril
des gens qui copule
[Applaudissements]
et son épouse excusez-moi si le home
avoir des problèmes sérieux avec le sait
ça écoutez moi bien je pense pas qu on
aura des problèmes
tu as tu as repris l'antenne donc tout
va bien non non à ce que la caméra reste
sur moi on ne peut pas voir ça puisqu'on
est dans tpm pays voilà c'est bon